look the aftermath of super wild card
weekend chris
we talked about multiple concerns with
officiating
multiple concerns with the proper
activation and deployment
of the replay review function including
the
somehow failure to overturn the ruling
on the field in
buffalo that that uh zach pascal hadn't
fumbled the football
the more than the failure of overturning
the bailout
everything to call the timeout that
saved the nfl
if that doesn't happen we're not only
going wait
that ball was a fumble and buffalo
recovered we're going they didn't even
review it
and it was like i mean but but wait
what's worse to not review it at all or
to review it and get it completely wrong
that's worse that is worse i think it's
so i i think it's worse i think
mcdermott
mcdermott exposed the dysfunction even
more by throwing
well he didn't throw a red challenge
flag he called a timeout so they could
wake up and realize we should probably
take a look at this they looked at it
and they didn't see
the clear and obvious evidence that that
pascal's
knees were off the ground before the
ball was ripped out of his possession
anyway have we got a discussion or a
statement about that yet
has ever been like the state you know
this here's the statement
there was no clear and obvious evidence
to overturn the ruling on the field
that's the statement that's all you ever
get
the statement from nfl officiating
typically on twitter
is one line and you know there's no
transparency anymore there's no videos
that are sent out every week explaining
challenging calls not like they did when
dean blandino was there mike pereira was
there
whoever has that job needs to be
able to convince people as to why
they've done what they did that's the
other side of this and as dean blandino
said they don't value that position
they need to value that position i.e pay
more money and they need to have sky
judges in every stadium to help the
on-field
crew realize when they need to make a
change before the replay function is
even activated then you've got another
buffer another layer of protection
to fix things before new york gets
involved yeah i mean i agree with you
that's certainly going to clean things
up
maybe hopefully speed up the process
that was one of the frustrating things
of this weekend
but i will say this like and i'm not
trying to like
you know fight you here or anything but
uh
the the sky just cause you kicked my ass
well the sky judge though is he going to
help out a situation like that the other
day
is it i mean if yes we still got it
wrong i'm not gonna say it was a fumble
okay no i'd like to think of sky jazz
well that's the thing yeah it could be
worse
if you have an incompetent sky judge i'm
assuming that the sky judge will at
least be sufficiently competent to see
that that was a fumble
and buzz down the referee on the field
that's a fumble with buffalo's ball and
then let the league office
do the replay review function hi i'm
mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports